>> Tomorrow on
The Social, the actor known for
starring in huge hits like The
OC and now Cardinal, Billy
Campbell.
[Audience cheers and applause]
>> Welcome back, everybody.
Alright, make sure you're
engaging with us right now in
real time online. We want to
share some news. Every time
there's something happening or
coming that we're really excited
and proud of, we do love to
share it with all of you. And
our President of Broadcasting
and Content for Bell Media, his
name is Randy Lennox, he is an
absolute legend in the music
industry. He is going to be
honoured for his extensive
contributions to Canada's music
scene, because it was just
announced a little earlier today
he'll be presented with the Walt
Grealis Special Achievement
Award happening at Juno week
and a huge gala. We want to send
you a huge congratulations,
Randy.
[Audience cheers and applause]
Yes, Very exciting.
And speaking of the Junos, the
2017 Juno Awards happen Sunday,
April 2nd. You can watch it
right here on CTV and we will
keep you posted as more
information about the show is
released. Big question that a
lot of people are pondering this
weekend is, well, should
real-live animals appear in film
and television or is
computer-generated imagery, or
CGI, the better option?
According to TMZ animal rights
activists-- animal rights
activists, that is, will
be picketing movie theatres
over the film A Dog's Purpose.
Recently a video surfaced of
what appears to be a frightened
German shepherd being forced
into a pool of rushing water
during the filming of the
movie.
[Audience booing]
So, the production company
told TMZ that they did not force
the dog to go through with the
stunt. Instead they called a
break, and filmed it once the
dog calmed down and was okay
with it. So this is a big
controversy because it's
affecting the film now. As the
actress on the panel, what's
your take on this?
>> It's interesting the CGI
option, because I shot a film
last summer and we had to-- we
had a scene with a bear. It was
supposed to scare us and the
director met with various
trainers, and in the end he
didn't trust them quite
enough. So basically it was
CGIed. But I feel like sometimes
it is true that on set there is
that feeling of because we are
filming fiction we can push
the limits. And it's as if we
weren't shooting reality. And
me, as a child actor-- I mean,
we are talking about animals
right now but to me it's the
same thing with child actors.
I have seen and I have
experienced moments myself.